biggest pay raise is one to Black
workers young people and low-wage
earners according to Wall Street Journal
black workers young workers and
low-income owners saw the largest pay
increases in 2022 due to tight labor
market and high inflation median weekly
earnings for all workers were 7.4
percent High year over year at the end
of 2022 the median race for black
Americans was 11.3 percent and weekly
pay workers
uh between 16 to 24 years old Rose by 10
the bottom 10 percent of wage earners
saw a pay increase of 10 percent
these pain creases were a welcome were a
welcome relief for those groups who have
experienced Decades of pain in the labor
market however wage gains and a broader
inflation has begun to cool and job
losses are forecasted for 2023 the rate
of raises between workers 16 to 24 and
other age groups widened in 2022 white
and Asian workers continue to earn more
than any other racial groups okay any
any thoughts on this article Tom
uh well first of all it certainly goes
against a narrative doesn't it evil
corporations don't do anything for
anybody and while you can look back at
inflation you can look at inflation over
time and say wow it should be higher it
should be this
seems to be a positive point of progress
that's that's what I see here I see a
positive point of progress
more progress needs to be done things
still have to you know I think move
forward but to say that you know that
what you're led to believe by mainstream
media is that evil corporations are
keeping wages down they're doing this
and this and this and yet there's data
points that are coming out here that
says some of the people that most needed
raises especially during inflation
actually receive raises I mean these are
double-digit percents
I look at it I look at it actually a
different way I I think this just comes
down to the the minimum wage debate I
mean what are we talking about here
these are young people low wage earners
black workers I think at least two out
of three for sure this comes down to
minimum wage this whole fight for 15
that's been transpiring for the last
five years now they're talking about
minimum wage 20 bucks certain places and
then you know minimum wage in New York
is a lot of different than Tuscaloosa
Alabama I think a lot of this is the
minimum wage debate and then
you know the minimum I think if you're a
worker and you're getting 12 bucks an
hour or 10 bucks an hour and you're
fighting for 15. I get it and you're
fighting for 15 for 20. I get it
but think about the business owner the
small business I mean you could talk
about this all day Pat
how do you make payroll sometimes you
know how do you and there's other parts
of the payroll that this is not my
wheelhouse but
um workman's comp type stuff right or
payroll tax these types of things that
as a small business owner these are
things that you need to be considering
and that the average workers just like
[__] it I want 20 bucks an hour that's
where I got it's 40 Grand now you just
went for 10 bucks an hour all all it
does when you raise the minimum wage is
it helps the big companies it hurts the
small companies let me give you an idea
what happened with capitalism this is
why capitalism works and this is why too
much government intervention gets in the
way watch this watch what the market
does what is the minimum wage in America
today today it's like seven or eight
bucks it's 725 or some number like that
okay where is it going to by July do you
know the number where it's going July
bucks it's going to 9.50 an hour by July
of this year okay do you know right now
what you get paid if you work at Walmart
an hour what's their minimum wage 12
bucks an hour do you know what it is at
Amazon and Target 2020 15 bucks an hour
wow so guess what Walmart's been having
a hard time doing
attracting people hiring people so
Walmart sat there and said dude we
cannot be given our minimum wage at 12
bucks Walmart just announced
starting wage to anybody they hire is
officially 14 bucks which by the way
it's still not 15 bucks which is Target
and Amazon so if an app if a person
wanted to go get a job and you're a 18
year old kid 17 year old kid 20 you're
like dude I just need a job that pays me
good to start off with you have to
choose between Walmart and you have to
choose between Target and Amazon where
you're going to whoever pays more yeah
Target and Amazon pay Buck more yeah so
you know what happens who takes a hit
no no Walmart takes a hit here you're
right yeah 100 but here the point I'm
trying to make too is the following
what did the government raises the
minimum wage from 725 to 950 has nothing
to do with this yeah nothing to do with
this because they still have to pay
they're still way above whatever the
minimum wage is however
the Walmarts of the world can afford 50
bucks an hour the Amazon and the you
know targets of the world can't afford
15 bucks an hour the small little shop
in Kansas who's been there for 42 years
business was passed down from Mom and
Dad to them they can't afford to go to
15 bucks an hour right across the street
there's a Walmart opens up okay kids out
of high school whose someone's son comes
and starts working for you now that
guy's son that guy's father says listen
instead of working for Joey's little
market that he has go to Walmart right
across the street Joey only pays 11
bucks an hour such and such pays 15
bucks an hour go to them you lose You're
Gonna Take a Hit so again one side
capitals and works Market dictates wages
government getting involved doesn't work
and if you do force people to pay a
higher minimum wage the small business
owners that produce 49 of all the jobs
in America take a massive hit you cannot
do that okay you cannot do that I'll
tell you one thing I've learned from you
is essentially what what the big guys
will say to grandstand versus what
actually happened so if you're Jeff
Bezos or who's the the new CEO of Amazon
Andy Jazzy Jazzy Jeff and well all
workers deserve 15 an hour and I'm I
totally Advocate bumping that up to 16
workers have rights let's get behind our
Workforce because they're saying that
publicly grandstanding but they know
they just took Tommy's toy store out of
business and Billy's Boutique out of
business and Patty pad cakes out a bit
like all these small little businesses
that you're talking about Kansas I can't
do 15 an hour I can't do 18 an hour I
can barely do 12. and so on the surface
the Andy Jazzy's of the world are going
to come out there in grandstand but
low-key it's because they're putting any
small competitors out of business and
that's how they develop their Monopoly
okay let's do a little math let's do a
little fast case study remember when New
York we goes back about seven years ago
said hey we're gonna do um you know
McDonald's and all these places and they
specifically call that fast food and
they said 15 an hour remember that
remember that whole thing okay
and you remember what showed up uh I
think it was a year and a half later
kiosks two ordering kiosks showed up and
two counter people were no longer needed
uh okay now watch this to order you're
saying order your food at the kiosk to
tap it in rather than ordering it at the
counter right yeah so there's two people
at the counter and direct chaos no at a
mid-sized McDonald's Watch What Happens
the two people are now up to 15 bucks an
hour the two kiosks I pay them
electricity so now I have two people
that's 30 bucks an hour but I have four
working units divide 30 by four
seven fifty yep wow now my labor my
total labor cost to take orders is 750
an hour because I have two humans and
two kiosks what also happens is the
large part of the market solves problems
that politicians cause and if you invoke
costs The Innovation is going to come
from Innovative companies that are
trying to solve that because they're
ultimately trying to be profitable and
make a return for the shareholders and
that's a great simple little case study
on how McDonald's was forced to pay 750
an hour but the true label costs for
four counter workers was seven was
forced to be paying 15 bucks an hour for
two humans which is 30 bucks over an
hour but they have two chaos working
divided by four it's back 750 an hour by
the way such a great case example
because we've all been to Walmart where
it's like uh self-checkout over here
yeah or you go to Walgreens or CVS it's
like now I'm the bagger now it's my job
to bag everything it's because when you
start raising the prices and they start
losing amount of employees they're going
to make you do the bagging Customer
because now there's half the employees
there and now you're incurring that cost
yeah now I gotta become a professional
Bag Boy because uh they're raising the
minimum what's wrong with being a bad
grade no you did nothing I'm sorry guys
I'm offended right yeah you know what I
said 170 million I know you've got to go
get a job you guys went a different
route on the store which was which was
great you know what I got from it when I
read biggest pay raises went to Black
workers yeah all were ever all we've
been told for God knows how long from
the left is this is a racist country
we're systemically racist from Pete
bootage saying Bridges and there's a
fact bridges are racist from Stacey
Abrams saying asking ideas for voting is
so racist that's a great headline to see
that we're not as racist as they're
saying if black people are are getting
these biggest pay races and I guess the
left they might be a little bit wrong
about how racist we are with the country
yeah but they but the boys need that
problem too of course you know pin us
pin us against each other that's a big
time but that's a great headline note
yeah that's amazing so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]